hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray now in the last
episode we were trying to figure out
what neural mod to be using and you guys
said that hacking is a very useful one
but you said that hacking doesn't get
useful until you get about to hacking 3
also useful is repair also useful is
necropsy because the benefit of a
necropsy is that I get more organs from
the Typhon which means that I'm going to
be able to use those to make more exotic
materials which is used in the
fabrication of neuro mods so I don't
know if that's like a direct correlation
but if it's like an it's like you know
in any economy you want to go for the
route that gives you more of the thing
that allows you to upgrade more so for
now I need physician to be able to get
to that point and I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna need physician because I seem to
be taking a lot of damage I'm not saying
I'm bad at this game I'm saying I'm just
new to this game Oh God
you'll be ready for a medical emergency
now let's get you to the main lobby what
I thought it was gonna be like a suction
cup you didn't tell me needles were
gonna jab into my brain okay oh hi
you're still hoping you're very shocked
about all this he's like I can't believe
they killed me with that [ __ ] okay
so um anyway I think we uh-huh I think
we found everything that we need to find
in this area we need to get to the lobby
area the skill recording room I don't
know what that's all about but I think
we've been everywhere around here except
for maybe in here oh no oh no that was
hacking level one oh no I could have
gotten in there I take it back load
loaded loaded back Sam check it back I'm
not above this not above this I am NOT
above this I'm a man who wants to stab
himself in the eye again to be able to
get hacking one because you guys told me
hacking wasn't gonna be able to aah
Frick I should have followed my into it
it's like I really am Morgan you I'm
just doing this over and over again
what's up Oh Thank You January it's the
second January there was a reason I did
that again hello dude oh ah but now I
need I wouldn't have gotten necropsy
anyway so that's fine but I didn't get
that these organs here so I got to make
sure I get all these oh wow that guy had
a whole bunch of stuff 9 millimeter
bullets am i gonna be getting a gun
anytime soon
Oh boink we OH hacking allows you to
bypass security systems protecting
keypads workstation and security
stations at higher levels you can act
robotic systems such as turrets navigate
the bitstream to reach the target once a
side press the prompted bit C hacking
fingers hacker voice I'm in found an
upper what you can use these to upgrade
weapons weapon kids don't allow you to
upgrade weapons you to use a weapon kit
select the weapon you wish to choose
upgrade Oh some upgrades of require
advanced skills ok select the weapon I
want to upgrade well I can upgrade my
glue gun to be able to spew more glue
everywhere that's something I've always
wanted to do I think unless I can
upgrade this thing no upgrade upgrade
okay I guess I can only upgrade this Oh
reduce the glue ammunition required
incapacitate handling range reload I'll
do this one I'll upgrade that I've
always wanted to be more efficient about
my glue I gotta shut up about that
anyway so I got that now so that's good
I guess I don't have a password for this
oh if I had hacking 2 security stations
track all the employees aboard
one what Oh
selecting an employee's name will unlock
an objective with tracking information
assuming their tracking bracelet is
still transmitting Wow
that lady on the right does not look
okay I'm just saying something's off
about that alrighty then that's good huh
well alright then Oh bring turrets up to
fabrication oh okay why oh but why
though okay whatever it doesn't matter
let's carry on we've wasted enough time
I know I've been I've been exploring the
environment a whole hell of a lot in
this game but that's just cuz like I'm
honestly so cure okay favorite wheel the
press mouse wheel dopin favorite wheel
must want to collect it okay so Mouse
wonder favorite wheel oh I can use a
medkit right from there oh that's good
and I got the bonus no I don't have the
bonus for medkit anymore because I don't
have that fur necropsy
it's like a trade off no matter what you
do but I'm gonna go for a necropsy next
if this will be useful in case I need to
break into any key pads that I come
across so I will be able to use that so
long as I can hack it okay which is not
always general guaranteed here don't
know why january's compliment me on my
skill hey how's it going friend it's my
buddy alrighty then no I am NOT why why
is there real views at all fake world
all I'm in space oh I'm in space I'm his
face I like space I like space a lot I
like space a lot oh hi okay I took this
tulip cuz of his face well geez tape
drive carry with leverage three leverage
allow me to carry that
pretty sure I can't leverage my way to
hauling giant boxes no what
ever I'm not gonna complain hello oh
that gives me healthy fancy that but
I've had enough to drink I guess well
goodbye I do who are you
oh that's no that's not what I wanted Oh
scuse me that's beautiful huh that's
beautiful okay Tallis one is open for
you to explore from the lobby you can
reach other are alright never mind then
access the video file okay I'm in a door
I saw that wait I saw that
[Music]
okay nevermind I thought I saw I almost
forgot for a second where I was and why
I was here I saw that
[Music]
yeah okay thought I saw something we
might be a little paranoid here but I
think it's for good reason
you can't trust anything or anyone ever
all right I'll take this used cigar
that's good for my health
okay oh hello shotgun shells am I gonna
get a shotgun anytime soon can I get in
here
I've got hacking skills wait there's no
stuffing there's a safe in there okay so
either way I need to get to my place of
some sort so that I can get something I
don't remember what okay why though but
why everyone seems to already be dead
hey glued I've got so much glue it's so
much more efficient you don't even know
the same glue anymore oh yeah you think
I'm a vault okay man I wish I had the
crowd see I'd be able to take these
tumors here I don't know if good they've
died what happened holy [ __ ] you're
beautiful
on a break elope with your beautiful dad
I need necropsy
I'm missing out on so much [ __ ] okay
neuro mods and compensation trans star
employees who perform at exemplary
levels are also eligible to see received
neuro Mons good I think that's good
right I hope righty then hello hi pretty
hearty hearty ho Oh psychotronics staff
only oh I don't know what that is hello
my bash this open all right never mind
then you all carry on you have a lovely
day yeah oh whoa good blood
great good Oh lovely I'll just be flower
picking for the rest of this duration
that looks like that looks flammable no
it's flammable looks extremely flammable
hello anybody want some blue in here
I've got an excess of blue it's very
efficient you'd be amazed at my glue
everyone would be amazed at my glue
hello all right find them okay I'll take
that agave plant clippings gonna make
some some sweet sweet agave nectar all
right
getting a lot of med kits which makes me
think that something bad is gonna happen
the space elevator early united states
dominance of the first operational space
elevator the white stork tower has
allowed them to control almost all
orbital activities and commerce now the
rest of the world is playing catch-up
the world unit of space industry lucy
has calculated that using the Stork
facility aden construction of a second
space elevator would result in the
construction costs that are one quarter
of the original understandably US
officials have balked at the idea of
helping competitors build a cheaper
platform that could give them a
competitive advantage stork
representatives maintained that a
sizeable investment risks for the
original platform justify the protection
of this economic space in the meantime
woozi has aggressively moved to purchase
ideal sites for future space elevators
essentially space age squatting well
that's good good to know people are
still squatting in the future Jesus
Christ you guys still spook no no
where'd you friend go huh give me your
tumors I want them real bad okay so he's
your guy is he blended in he's blended
in isn't it hi where was he where was he
all right you know what I'm gonna forget
about him I'll come back and get him
later eyes why hello okay I'm gonna
pretend like that's nothing apparently
did these Peas I got a lemon-peel let me
just stuff that in my pants why thank
you I appreciate that I'd like to think
that I'm not a guy's what the [ __ ]
Jesus Christmas oh the turret gun hey
Dirk can you take care of that guy -
[Music]
thank you turn that turns useful I need
to waste any of my glue I value my very
very efficient glue hello
all right okay yeah I'll take why did
you have biohazard waste on you why uh
sky king pomegranate oh hi hello okay
hello key card required an oxygen
detected beyond this point proceed at
your own risk for the sake of my own
risk I don't think I'm gonna go over
there Oh God
Oh what happened to you what happened
alrighty then carrying on oh yeah I need
to get to my office I almost forgotten
about my frickin office is already then
husky no maybe I don't know I don't know
man okay so it's up there okay so I got
to get up there may be alien threats
alien wait alien threat oh well these
turrets are awesome it's just an alien
threat though so when it says alien
threat is it talking like for real
aliens here because I was under the
impression that these things were things
that this corporation whatever it is
Transtar I think it was that this
corporation had made not that it was
utilizing aliens so my understanding
right now as it stands what I know those
thus far is that I may not be human but
I may be alien or something along those
lines I'm not a hundred percent sure can
I act that please tell me I can act that
no apparently not okay
but that doesn't make the most sense
I've ever heard that just makes a little
too high who's that in Rome odd yes give
me you thank you thank you for that I
think anyway thank you I'll take that as
well thank you
pretty good okay so I need to go up I've
wasted enough time gun
I just hi oh yeah alright just wanna
check I was pretty sure that was gonna
be the real one but that means there's a
trash can up there ha ha ha big load
include you up
jeezum you sack of [ __ ] you sat oh my oh
oh
the trauma center wait I needed to go
into the trauma center for some reason
okay Oh bullet blam blam blam blam below
flammie well lemme Blamey below me whoa
hello I'm up here now oh my god that's
so cool I hope I get to go out there oh
I hope I get to go out there oh I hope I
get to go out there I mean it'd be very
dead space if it did that but in a way
this game does kind of give off a bit of
dead space vods maybe like a mixture of
dead space and Bioshock is actually a
good way to describe this game right
that's a gun can I have that but there's
two guns
it's one of those of mimic
all right your dad just a bunch of
dittos from pokemons oh hi
okay there's a turret over there that's
gonna be useful it's a nice office or
what's this Oh for the drama center oh
good I can go down there and I can go
for dr. below don't let their bladder
okay emails volunteer attitude miss
Goodwin I'm gonna need more support the
volunteers are agitated more than usual
this morning eleven threatened to bash
my head and if I didn't let him out to
stretch his legs when you get the key up
here the key code is 7703 not the old
number on file and pretty sure they've
been watching me punch that in so I
changed it for where what are you
talking about seven seven zero three
where is that code two
okay thank you oh no hang on to follow
up on the previous request I was
wondering if there'd been any updates on
Gustav Leitner's visit is it still
taking place and if so would it be
possible to get a copy of this itinerary
I would love a chance to meet him before
the neuro mapping procedure of course
let's see
dr. igloo I relayed your previous
request and we'll see what we can do
about that but there are no guarantees
the schedule for the visit is tight and
may not allow for a face-to-face I'll
let you know when I have more details
sincerely Bianca tell us one volunteer
and guest liaison okay thank you
yeah it gooiest showed up quite quiet
and polite he shook late in his hand
like he was afraid of breaking him asked
him to sign an album he brought Lightner
seemed flattered so that was a plus we
tried to make him comfortable his
condition hasn't stopped him from
craving a cigarette fingers were
twitching it's too bad such a talent no
wonder he wanted to get scanned get
scanned for what what are they scanning
for some sort of brain mapping here is
there like some sort of soma application
here I don't know what it's all for
well that's super weird and I got a code
but I don't know what it's do maybe some
volunteer headquarters oh this office
dilapidated than the last one principles
of neuroscience the brain was considered
to warm wet and noisy for singing
seemingly delicate quantum processes
however the discovery of quantum
coherence in biological processes such
as plant photosynthesis avian navigation
and our own sense of smell paved the way
for eventual discovery of quantum
vibrations inside the microtubules of
neurons okay so our brains are a little
bit of a quantum computer is that what
we're talking about here sylveon I'm
trusting you with my brain you do good
work so hopefully that continues listen
if the tests go well don't go well if
something happens let Alex know that I
know it wasn't his fault I signed up for
this also if the test dragged on
consider removing your office down to
sim less hassle and you can always move
back after we celebrate our success from
Morgan you supposedly that's me awaiting
please Riven the main boxes to my new
office in neural Monde division so who
is this
this is Sylvain bellamy oh that's
Bellomy that's dr. Bellamy that's the
guy that is supposedly dead because he's
been attacked by something the nature of
consciousness how can this be
fundamental
I've already read that one about the
consciousness thing oh man okay moving
on moving on moving on hello moving on
moving on moving on here oh is this a
password OMG hot boss you talked about
me oh you're talking about Jason Chang
this is my office right to PI thank you
thank you how do you know that how do
you know that all right whatever
Jason main screwed the keypad in my
office had to set it up 2-0 four five
one I'll be in the sim labs for a while
so if you need anything to help yourself
well I just wait I was just about to
find that out where'd they come from
I don't know where I got that I don't
think I got it from right here dude
adjustment
I don't need an attitude adjustment
especially not with bullets okay zero
four five one wow that would take a half
before I guess I got good security on my
own office here my office yeah sure I
believe that
oh yeah sure it has okay whatever you
say oh oh hello hello hello I don't know
what I got but I got something good
Oh DeMorgan you sweet I don't know where
that is but I got that aisle fabricator
oh I can make a wrench I don't have
enough ingredients fabricators can be
used to create weapons dozens of useful
tools aboard Talos one each item
fabricated consume similar combination
of organic mineral and synthetic ah
those are the materials that I just
picked some up and I've got my
inventories getting full suit
modification skill increases inventory
sauce okay I'll get that but I've got
synthetic material organic material and
mineral material so that's good oh by a
half refrigerate a recycle immediately
okay I'll just carry it on me I'd rather
risk disease and keep this really cool
bio waste so if I can face editor
[Music]
ooh-ah-ha
so this is how oh it gives materials
okay so that's why I have this stuff
so what's junk and what's not junk is it
the gray stuff
okay I'm gonna trust this I don't know
this understand I mean I'm assuming it's
if a lemon-peel is gray I'm assuming
that means it's junk right - organ
contains exotic material which is used
to fabricate new robots that's what I
need to crop c4 so do I do I recycle
that I think I recycled that and then
there was an auto sword okay that is
helpful I guess recycle yeah oh yeah
okay so I can take these and I can
fabricate stuff right can I make more
neural mods I don't have the recipe for
it damnit who was this operator
designator dispense designator dispenser
I am NOT doing words correctly right now
okay anyway whoa baseball glove oh the
mother lode
oh yes please hello I got the plan you
requested it's in your safe okay well I
know my my my password I could hack it
now I know my password it's fine I know
it hello you made it from January
zom I don't know what that means I still
don't know what happened I put it behind
me but there's no reason we can't be
civil you passed me in the hall today
and you look through me if you're angry
at something I did tell me and we can
talk about it pretending you don't even
know who I am isn't gonna help we still
have to work together oh okay so I had a
relationship of some sort
Morgan has requested your terminal logs
are sent set to be automatically
forwarded to your suite in crew quarters
and the supplies from Hardware sent up
let me know if you get they get to you
alright and if not I'll get it resolved
like last week I'll make sure you aren't
disturbed for the interim let me know if
there's anything else I can do hold down
the fort outside your office okay cool
cool cool cool hello ah the whole
family's here everyone
looking awfully grim and also that's a
rather ominous symbol on my jacket
quote-unquote oh wait I can make glue
ammo I can make more glue my glue
nevermind you know what I'm not gonna
even go there I'm gonna cut it with the
glue jokes but if supposedly if I do
this right I can make more glue Oh is
there any reason I shouldn't be making
as much glue as I possibly can it seems
like that's good a bit of salvageable
here so that's good okay so in Kennedy's
second term the space race reached new
heights and without his support may have
sputtered completely a succession of
moon launches heralded the coming of an
accelerated energetic space program both
within the halls of government and in
the public eye unusual at the time
especially in contrast to Kennedy's
first term rather than simply being a
race between two powers the Soviets in
the United States seemed to be reaching
out to space together okay then so watch
me Morgan hello Morgan this LGV file
should clear things up make sure you're
alone when hit play any mimics in here
play okay
oh hello I supposed to step in there Wow
whoa I didn't mean to do that I did not
mean to do that if I'm talking to myself
it must be oh [ __ ]
your memories shuffle [ __ ] oh sorry
minute weights are the first thing you
need to know is you can trust [ __ ]
god damn it back up of you and me okay
hang on
it knows what you've forgotten we've
been testing a new kind of neural mod
based on the type and organisms mapping
their neural patterns onto ours
problem is when you uninstall a neural
mod it resets your memory back to the
moment you first put it in that's why
you forget there supposed to be a
process to bring you back up to speed
between test runs but someone could just
skip that part turn a single day into
your entire life no that's exactly what
Alex did the question is why
you're not gonna like what I have to say
next oh god why did I break that but
there's something back here what is
there where am i okay alright okay Alex
if that is your real name okay but that
room that room was right outside of the
the place where I woke up from where
they were containing everything but five
one five zero that is the key code to
the safe in the original area where I
just was now it'd be a long trek to go
back there I may go back there at some
point but now I know that this quick and
painless is pod what are you talking
about quick and painless you try to
execute people what are you talking
about but either way if I go back there
eventually which I'm sure I will at some
point in this game I will open that safe
but probably not in this episode take
advantage of here mom I know how to
fight I know how to shoot my glue at the
enemy you tell me you don't know think I
know how do that
oh hi I'm gonna go back to the turret
hey buddy want to find me over here oh
mistake mistake baby what a mistake you
made okay
hi hi how's it going over there there's
a gun and I want it okay got that one I
called that totally called that sorry oh
I'd you twitch bullets
okay good old-fashioned 9-millimeter
silenced pistol so what good is this
gonna do me in the face of the Typhon of
the Typhon particularly susceptible to
bullets I'm gonna say this yes no I
wasn't sure about anything though all
right any more neural mods for me to get
nope okay all right then oh good paper
and [ __ ] so glad I'm gathering up
ooh this is where I'm supposed to go it
looks like that might be a yes all
righty then I might need to make a run
to the the salvager yawn I'm getting
pretty full up on here so I'm probably
gonna make a run to the salvager and
also how did the corpse get all the way
over here what is this I don't have
repair I know I've got neuro mods but
I'm trying to go for a necropsy here oh
that wasn't as glorious as I thought it
was gonna be so before I go there I'm
just gonna run back real quick I'm gonna
run back real quick I'm gonna salvage
what I got and then I'm gonna try to
craft more bullets because that's gonna
be good for me ah thank you for that and
also if I can ever find a key card to
the thing boss
hi oh hi hi
okay you want to get glute bunny boo you
want to get glued it's not a turret
nearby is there alright buddy buddy
alright okay so how you doing how you
doing
yeah oh Jesus no need to be so angry
about everything
some things aren't worth getting angry
about oh yeah oh yeah you keep walking
over there your big dumb doof doof get
ready
I mean I'm gonna glue him and then I'm
gonna shoot Yuri Yuri
wait Yuri his name is Yuri was
surprisingly effective
but why was why was it's named Yuri if
it's name was your Yuri Kimura
it doesn't say phantom it doesn't say
mimic that says Yuri Kimura like I'm not
going out of my mind here that's Yuri
Kimura and there's a reason this is Yuri
Kimura
Noura mod neuro mod installed technician
the turret said something about aliens
these neuro mods must be something
derived from these - which aren't made
by this company these must be actual
legit entities that we're trying to
reverse engineer oh [ __ ]
oh hell yeah oh my god Oh Frick dude
here comes another I gem I've got eight
holy [ __ ] okay I can get into cropsy
okay yeah I can do this
oh good I don't need to stab myself in
the eye again that's good but then I can
do necropsy which means I'm gonna
eventually get more neural mods oh yeah
and then I can get I can get leverage I
could get repair I could get
conditioning I can combat focus stealth
Oh that'd be nice I'm gonna go for the
the level one things just because
they're cheap and they open up the doors
for a lot especially this repair one and
I've already seen things that need to be
repaired so that's good I don't think I
definitely need these things because I
seem to be doing a lot better about
damage so it's probably good
let's see exports from Elias black to
Eureka Maura you can't ship it home it's
already been noticed one month pay makes
it go away so someone who was trying to
extort something here but I'm thinking
because Yuri Kimura that just suggested
she was doing some shady stuff she or he
I have no idea was doing some shady
stuff and that means something right
that means something anyway I don't
think we have to worry too much about
the side effects from what I gathered
it's just a little pinprick the eye
right Brig I mean it looks scary but I
think if we can get advertising to push
some of the more appealing pros of NMS
we can shift public attention to that
I'm not too worried about the redeye
stuff either I don't think any one
person in the public sector is gonna
manage to get their hands on that many
NMS at one time not these prices what I
find far more worrying though are these
reports of memory loss during nm removal
I mean amnesia seriously we can rewire a
person's brain give them any skill we've
won but we can't avoid resetting their
head back to the moment they got that
[ __ ] installed if we decide to take it
out if this leaks it'll kill nm sales
doesn't matter if you need specialized
equipment of training to take one out no
one wants to risk losing years of their
life just for the ability to speak
French this can't even go in the fine
print as far as the customer is
concerned NMS are permanent okay so
that's that's a side effect I think we
already knew about but that's still
[ __ ] god dammit [ __ ] you dude [ __ ]
you oh thank you for that well at least
I got in the cropsy and I can do that I
already knew about that one ah boy
Oh [ __ ] turnip what's this oh oh
the hunters bolt caster launches foam
darts which zero damage also known for
its ability to annoy coworkers distract
enemies and remotely trigger buttons and
screens use mouse one to fire your toy
gun and harder reload oh I've got a nerf
crossbow good I guess okay but okay but
there was a benefit to coming over
because I got a whole bunch of neural
mods which is good because now at least
I can go or anything to go that's the
space elevator that's a baseball glove
oh yeah I totally forgot I was going I
was going to get recycling I was just
about to go recycle ooh I know a secret
path when I see one and this is
definitely a secret path hello Oh
[ __ ] god damn it stop it with that
[ __ ] so [ __ ] I was doing great not
tanky oh [ __ ] I'll come get you later I
didn't realize I could break the floor
like that
[ __ ] man these guys are [ __ ] with me
whoa
that's nice ha Bisky my arms have gotten
stronger we got a lot of med kits holy
[ __ ] these guys are [ __ ] with me i
hack this oh I can alright let's see if
I can hack something in here alright got
it play a little game here
Oh Nancy I did it okay I don't know what
that did but he did it
oh I Oh what do you see in the glass
what are you talking about what are you
talking about I'm running out of bullets
I've got enough glue and I've got four
why there's a there's a thing right next
to him I'm doing the damage integrity is
really the time oh okay I don't have
enough bullets there was another one in
there it doesn't seem to add no decide
she was killing his dude I got enough
for one shot on like that can in there
oh no oh God
oh I shoulda reloaded I'm a bash gonna
bash it whoa where'd you go where to go
where to go where to go oh no need for
that no need for that
whoa you had a lot of stuff on you oh
[ __ ] okay oh my god yet even more they
both had stuff on them oh I got a whole
bunch of [ __ ] okay I got three upgrade
kits oh [ __ ] okay so I'm an upgrade this
I guess upgrade that bad boy to more
accuracy firepower first then I'm gonna
upgrade the glue gun cuz it's really
useful to reload speed maybe reload and
then I could always use more handling
the range is fine I would like to be
able to move faster while I use it
though okay that's good I need to I need
to dump my salvage I keep forgetting I
was supposed to go dump my salvage and
then I kept getting distracted security
office okay I got done that's good I
think that security officers downstairs
by the shuttle bay if I remember
correctly authorized personnel clearance
required
okay keycard only no hacking on that one
where am I
our tech is proprietor your ideas are
confidential okay all right
Jesus okay well that was good whoa for
captain there sorry I blinked and
thought I was in a different dimension
or something
so where's oh oh oh okay okay all right
I'm down with that well oh my health is
low geez all right there we go I'm all
full up I need to eat my food Nick I saw
that I saw that I saw that oh oh
[Music]
Nelly and I'm gonna guess you are one
too but I don't have enough get you
all right I see how this is going I
don't know that doesn't seem to work but
I have a funny feeling there's another
one in here Oh recyclable Oh handy okay
gray I've got a lot of food here but I'm
gonna eat it next time that I get hurt
which I'm sure I'm going to be okay wait
is that the fast way to do it yes please
thank you I like that
very convenient for me to have that
there international art smoke signals
Alex you commented our art inspires
fires our creativity makes us look
beyond our present circumstances to what
might be possible
well thanks Alex big bro you're such an
inspiration for everybody I was wrong
okay welcome hey stop stop being such a
douche for one goddamn second of your
goddamn life I'm gonna drink this and
eat this
that's gotta be the end of that you guys
are gonna shut up you guys are gonna let
me live so I can get back to my goddamn
office which is what I meant to do the
whole time here or psychosom why where
what did I just do need it's up high
hopping up on things no no no no clap
and your dad now I love that necropsy
hopefully that's gonna pay off in the
long run because right now it doesn't
seem like I'm gonna be able to get
anything except a lot of food here but
for now pioneers of working aboard Space
Station is comparable were working on
Earth tend to forget that they're in
space and to adapt well deep corner of
Luna Pole permanently shadowed and
surrounded by kilometres of ice beneath
the pypy is a vast network of clamor
tones where hydrogen helium 3 hydrogen
and platinum are mined this is a dark
cold enough and terrifying workspace cut
off from the warmth glove earth which
extracts a heavy and often fatal toll on
the crew good
great so I'm I'm guessing this place
called Pythias is uh is where I'm gonna
be going next I'm probably gonna go down
to PI theists probably where they found
the Typhon I'm gonna call that right now
we in that mining station on PI theist
is where they found the pot the Typhon
and that's where this came from and
that's where it is and that's why it's
terrifying cuz it's all in your mind
that's what it is isn't it how close am
i guys how close how close am I just
sound a little bit that I got here I'm a
mimic I'm a mimic I'm calling out right
now I'm a mimic because of the neural
mods and the constant installation
because the neuro mods are based on the
Thai phones which are aliens which is
why URI was a Typhon and she got
infected by it and turned into one of
them because they're how close am i how
nailed on the head do I got that bad boy
I feel a hundred percent competent about
that one I feel a hundred percent
confident that I got it all on luck oh
god I need to go in the trauma centre
freak there's so many things to explore
I keep forgetting what I need to do okay
uh-oh
if I just hold down F that's gonna but
that's it that's way easier but I've got
all this food I either need to eat or do
something with it I guess I guess I
could recycle it I guess would it be
would it be a waste would it be a waste
to recycle all this did you get a lot of
it I mean I don't need all that much of
it I guess I'm doing okay I'm not I'm
not dying horribly which is nice I can
live on the edge I got 101 neural mod
here that I didn't even know I had so
that's good
[Music]
bling blong okay so I'm out of here god
I got so sidetracked there but that's
just like that's what I actually really
like about this game is like it's it's
cotton can I drop down here safely oh
okay fine I can like I can just explore
for a while and I can just okay is it
because our brains are being scrambled
this is like very dead Spacey I'm not
gonna lie about this but there's a very
dead spazzy and I got the security
office key which means I might be able
to get something here hello ah this all
looks very bad okay then so this seems
like these are all in error and not
usable that is broke to [ __ ] that's all
broke there's nothing here good those
emails how about now Elias anyone help
Nils again not a hoax life or death help
us help were trapped in the shuttle bay
please answer urgent work news Morgan
asked us what the current code is ask if
it was requested or if we chose it then
asked us for a new one it's unusual last
time you asked I was right there so I
told him the coding gave me a blank look
a code we'd set less than a week ago
maybe he's testing our response time huh
weird
okay then Oh another weapon upgrades
getting lots of those that's good
[Music]
yeah yeah okay got that C thrown
tactical shotgun provides maximum damage
at close range effectiveness falls off
significantly at longer range so I got
to be point-blank on these bad boys
judges 526 her hand she put to the tent
peg in her hand right hand to the
Workmen's hammer and with the hammer she
smokes so Sarah she smoked through his
head yay she pierced and struck through
his temples okay that's nice I can't
hack that okay
day two I woke up still in the street
and m35 truck was stopped near me and
the driver was yelling at me to get in
there were several people in the back
four or five soldiers in Novato dungeons
facility civilians including children I
got in the truck and someone gave me a
bottle of water that's what was
happening in a soldier a soldier
shrugged I told him I drove driven the
m35 during my service people in the
truck were crying and I looked back the
pink smoke was now mixed with gray and
squirreling high in the sky there was so
much of it and seemed to cover the
entire city we kept picking up people
until the truck was full before we got
to the highway we heard shooting
the soldiers climbed down and readied
their weapons the commander told me to
drive the truck as far as possible to
the West than when they ran toward the
shooting that's weird that's super weird
I know you probably have your hands full
right now but we need you to send a
security detail to detain Dmitri Bowser
we witnessed the incident and he's
pretty shaken we're not sure how stable
he is at the moment make an assessment
and hold him indefinitely if necessary
use discretion ma'am you know I went to
the doctor about sleeping all that I got
pills but still been seeing things after
game night I was cleaning up in a chair
moved by itself
I'm not crazy like you know who I'm
sending this because I just after the
alert I heard something in the vent over
security I thought I saw something black
up there we need to check this out
because I'm starting to think there's
something on the station that we don't
know about like mimics please add
Michaela
Ellucian to the watchlist she's
currently performing your duties her
condition makes for a potential security
risk and we may need leverage her access
should be restricted to work in crew
facilities please don't let her anywhere
near the labs also flag any
communication between her and dr. Gallo
goes out of the psychotronics medical is
beginning to suspect she was white noise
so the fact she's falsified her records
what is white noise normally I'd
advocate knurl mod removal but her
condition prevents this please keep me
appraised plus Sarah I hope I need your
help tracking down a missing key card
this should be one of your highest
priorities it's labeled EP 101 please
let me know as soon as you find it from
Alex okay Dimitri's being held door code
changed it to one one to nine okay thank
you I don't know what the holding room
is is this a holding room is this the
holding room this is the holding room
okay all right
who's in here again not that could act
it but I'm once you nine I guess oh god
damn it
[ __ ] years old
it's [ __ ] oh my god wait
so that's Dimitri Bowser what oh the
mimic was the chair he was on Oh miss
Eleazar I don't know what I saw but I
was just trying to do my job now I
worried I might not get a chance to talk
to you so I'm writing this I don't
recall the last time I was scared but
what happened to sim I can't get it out
of my head whatever's happening I want
to help not sit here in this room I'm
starting to feel like people on station
haven't been shooting straight like what
they do actually do in psychotronics no
one I talked to goes in there and Yuri
Kimura has unnumbered Nura mods in her
office that I thought you should know
about Yuri Kimura that's the one that
was in her office man what is going on
here what is happening I was just I
literally was just trying to go back and
salvage himself before I continued on to
the main quest I got so sidetracked but
it's fascinating it's fascinating
download area map it's fascinating
there's just so much here I haven't been
able to go anywhere and I don't care
it's awesome and what is going on in
psychotronics what is happening over
there look I have no idea and I love it
I love it so much this is so cool but
now I'm finally go back up to my office
so that I can salvage some stuff and I
still need to go into there let me go in
here first
chase one last stop before I go where I
need to go because supposedly this is
where Bellamy is or belaney or whatever
it is
hello I'll take that yes how full is my
inventory right now not for me that's
right I forgot that I actually found
oh it's sylveon sylvain Bellamy tracing
break traffic with that lava tracking
bracelet okay so I don't have his
tracking bracelet so that means I can't
track him through the system right
download area map okay
so okay so that helped with the trauma
center I think okay but that's fine okay
that's fine
so what I need to do is I need to find
dr. Bellamy who is the NSP being dual
administered to inventory shows the case
of the booster shots are missing sorry
should have informed you NSP showers for
cheap Ellucian mild CC on physio nimac
physiognomy fatigue should have logged
it man these words Alejandra please come
see me can you transfer her charts and
family records as well weird I can't
pull those records up there none the
system still want me to swing by is that
the person is that the person they were
calling something about white and noise
is that what that was about
attention all security officers in
trauma you have multiple people on route
with injuries whoa as well as possible
fatality one of them is dr. Sylvain
Bellamy do not take him to the trauma
center he must be taken to sect Ronix
this is an extremely grave security and
health issue I repeat do not admit mr.
SIL dr. Sylvain belney to the trauma
center
take him to psychotronics immediately
Alex so he's not here that's why his
collar was here Melanie's not here he's
in psychotronics hello thank you for
that so how do I get to psychotronics hi
oh hello
was that guy on fire why is that guy on
fire
Garfield what what the [ __ ] is going on
here
they hear that okay so I'm gonna try to
be sneaky about this because that one's
on fire so I'm assuming is bad
oh yeah you heard that didn't you well
you you heard that oh yeah you heard
that you heard that oh yeah come on come
on little closer let me get you a
shotgun right to the face how about that
huh what's up man oh you both coming
don't ya well you're both are coming I
don't know if that's good that both of
you are coming but oh oh my god oh I
need to reload my glue okay all right
you wanna dance
[Music]
holy [ __ ] dude that guy's tough that
guy's tough I was not prepared for that
I was not prepared for that okay so what
I need to do is I need to lead them to
the explosive things because I think
that yeah okay there we go
and then the utilities I need to get the
area map again god dammit I need that I
need to save more there is a quick save
to this one but now I have all this
stuff and I got the materials I need
right there I get that okay so I need to
lead them
[Music]
those that's not what I meant to do then
I just set off the explosives did I just
set off the explosives I think I did oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god
okay there's someone here I can take
care of the little guy oh whoa that fire
guy is ridiculous the guy's ridiculous
well they're supposed to handle that she
sums okay so there's more explosive
cancers over here I just got a throw
madam cuz I got my super throw ability
now but if I can throw it at him you
just drop it for a second I'm gonna get
my pistol out if I throw it
laughter whoa I guess if I just throw
those it does it okay so the glue
doesn't seem to do anything to him but
if I just throw these at him he's
already on fire that's why it works
that makes sense okay where are you
going buddy where you going some of this
Oh hurt you okay all right I'm gonna get
this guy not with the crossbow I need to
take that off my favorites cuz that is
not helpful
BAM holy [ __ ] this is where you were to
go hello where are you come in [ __ ] okay
I got him though man gave me a weapon my
man those guys give great [ __ ] those
guys give great [ __ ] hello hi hello mine
could have Trevor jae-young
mind-controlled what does that mean
hello I can't hack that on our code okay
I'm gonna I'll come back to you when I I
figure out why you're in there I have a
bad feeling about you being in there but
alright so why is he mind control so
there is something about this and I'm
willing to bet that has something to do
with the psychotronics like all the
psychotronics I come in here Oh free new
Raimondo I like that I like that I like
that a lot oh-ho-ho hi operator
requesting new operator sorry hi
[Music]
thank you well that's awesome free
healing well ha ahem well that's handy
that's handy-dandy okay a patient
positive tested positive for
non-small-cell lung cancer
Gustav Lightner patient did not list any
ailments on the submission form prior to
being taken to the skill recorder
contact this patient immediately if
patient is still in Tallis one have him
report to the Tama Center as soon as
possible okay wait noise Oh white noise
more often called white noise due to the
tell-tale spots tend to be like static
in the victims eyes white noise isn't
just a medical condition and it's more
than the wild almost witch doctor like
claims of psychic ability dr. Deyo egg
way anyone its disenfranchisement it
says the victim can never have a neuroma
nor can their brain be mapped it's the
end of everything that is about a person
who's trans hard to decide will we let
them add the biological caste system to
the human race what what the brain can't
be mapped so you are talking about brain
scans like soma are you are you oh okay
all right then hi okay hello
oh good excuse me I'm just gonna take
some biohazard away from ear is that
your biohazard oh good for biohazard oh
good
is this where they map the brain it's so
weird
so there is something to that
there's gotta be right no I'm not shut
up
shut up you [ __ ] oh hi don't mind me
taking your bananas you're planning on a
vacation eh oh no that's the same test I
just took Jesus he's a good cop
good cop good cop the typical
interrogation sceptic portrayed by
entertainment media is stubborn clever
nor even arrogant entering into a verbal
sparring match with the interrogating
officer while this mistake makes for
good drama it's a poor representation of
actual cases it is important to note
that the majority of suspects want to
talk let them provide some prompts but
only keep the words flowing do not
attempt to direct them but just keep
them talking my experience in case
studies back this has been that most
people will move toward the information
you want to know if you just listen to
them and reaffirm their assumptions when
they need it ok I don't know what that's
for I don't think anyone hears being
studies show that there's significant
likelihood of behavioral conditions and
psychiatric disorders emerging from the
population of crew station for longer
than 3 months
impacts of behavioral issues are
minimized with appropriate tools for
monitoring mood at predicting risk while
including as many earth-like amenities
as possible ok this is all just medical
stuff hey Matt have another one of my
people presented soon no from you for
fatigue I just want to make sure it's
legit or there are a lot of people
coming to you for stress-related
complaints or is it my imagination
Trevor young I don't know what to tell
you he walked into an experiment without
a psycho scope and it went sideways we
couldn't contain it after that what they
controlled him my suspicion that the
Typhon can force other beings to
empathize with them maybe further down
the road we can find a way to reverse
engineer this get them to empathize with
us please keep mr. young in quarantine
for the time being you have my thanks
what's that talking about please keep
staff away from the quarantine area we
have a potentially contagious subject in
there who is suffering from memory loss
at this time dr. Cole and myself should
have access police at the new cone 2 6 9
6 8 something about a psycho scope I'm
assuming that's taking place in
psychotronics
to do with the Typhon session logs - ah
sorry meant to carry that I guess sorry
I'm sorry
I don't know why I was so angry at that
white board that white board just
deserved it did you see the way it
looked at me yeah I think so please
contact a qualified engineer okay broken
cooler fan note Wade please please
please with a cherry on top fix the
medical operator that's been sitting on
your desk okay I'm gonna put away that
because that's dangerous just to have in
my hands to be able to shoot at any
moment sorry what kind of a I'm a bull
in a china shop Oh
operator broken well this isn't the one
I shot so I don't know why I need to
repair this anyway because I've already
got one out there there might be like a
special reason maybe that meant a
collaborator okay alright you know what
I'm going to just take a little bit of a
breather and take all this in I know I
meant to get in electric shock
if you're having trouble accessing a
system please send a Health Alert for
security huh okay I'm gonna put the
brakes on for now and in this episode
here because I
I literally just stumbled into a world
of everything I had no idea I was gonna
die but it's awesome there's so much
here I didn't mean to do this completion
of style I just kind of fell into it man
I'll get back to my main objective over
there in just a second but I've got a
code to that guy's door so I'm gonna
find out what uh what that's all about
in the next episode because something's
going on here in psychotronics some
reason and I don't know why but I will
find out so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]